hey everyone it's Mike Votto's and
welcome to the order flows market
analysis for Friday September 29 2017
it's month-end
and what I'll talk about I spent some
time talking about today is the USDA
report the USDA quarterly grain stocks
report came out this morning and it
showed lower than expected stocks for
soybeans so soybean futures had a
positive response but you know the
weekly still has still looking at weekly
losses amid harvest pressure so you know
I want to talk about that you know if
for those that don't really trade don't
really follow the grains you have the
USDA grain the USDA report which comes
out is like the non-farm payrolls right
the unemployment number in the equities
and and financial markets the USDA grain
report is you know similar to that for
grain traders right this is the big
number this is you know the number that
they always weighed out for and comes
out at 11:00 a.m. Chicago time so it
comes out you know right in the middle
of the session so it's a it's it's
you'll see I'll show you a grain chart
I'll show your story being chart and you
can see how the market reacted to it
it's you know people think the grains
and they're slow moving they don't
really move but you sometimes there are
very explosive moves but before we begin
and go through a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains natural risk
and it's not for every investor and
investor could potentially lose all and
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those were sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results as usual the same tools we use
in this presentation as in all
presentations the order flows trader
software which is the volume footprint
chart Delta scalper which is an
additional indicator that reads the
Delta for you and analyzes it and the
price rejector which does looks forward
price rejection in the market now you
know before we begin I just want to put
this out there you know the Delta scale
for the price rejector these indicators
do not have sound abilities there's a
reason for that right is because myself
and most of the traders that use it
follow multiple markets on multiple
timeframes so if you have a sound going
off as soon as an indicator is you know
gives a signal alright if you know if
you're trading one market down one
timeframe okay but if you're trading say
four markets on you know two or three
different types of timeframes you're
looking at ten or twelve charts and so
if you got you know sound alerts going
off and the markets moving it's gonna
confuse the heck out of you
now especially if you know the way these
indicators are programmed right as a bar
is forming in them as the bar is forming
if the conditions are met it will give a
signal okay if the bar is still forming
and the conditions are no longer met the
signal disappears and then if it goes
back while the bar is forming and gives
a signal again because you know I said
it's reading the Delta Delta is changing
until the bar is closed once the bar is
closed and the signal prints it will not
reprint okay period
so but as the bar is forming if the
signal is appearing it's not appearing
as you know if it's a it's borderline
right because it does a calculation by
reading the Delta and you know reading
some other parts of price action if it's
not met if it's met then not met met not
met it'll go on and off off on and off
it'll show an actual not show so if you
have a sound feature to show every time
it happens it is Karine it's gonna make
a sound not make a sound mix on another
sound like that and it could be quite
confusing that's why we don't have the
sound in there okay that's why well I
said you know if you're just sticking to
one market on one timeframe
yeah it might be useful to you in that
case I suggest you go to there is
another vendor out there that sells a
simple sound alert let me see if I could
find it for you anyway I can't find it
right now but I'm pretty sure I saw
another indicator vendor that sells a
sound alert feature that you could plug
on top of a indicator but anyway I mean
you got you know everyone wants
everything handed to them you know you
gotta do the research yourself that
technology is out there but that's why I
don't have it in there and I don't want
it in there all right
I've spent a lot of time training a lot
of markets at the same time and honestly
I get confused with it that's why I
don't use it so anyway that said let's
jump into these markets do I start
all right well start with soybeans
really quick I'll pull up the normal bar
chart just give an idea of what the
market did when the number came out the
USDA report you can see it was just sort
of trading here kind of quite this is a
5-minute being chart and we went from
9:57 we shot up over the next five
minutes all the way up to 966 almost
nine sixty seven so that that you know
what that equates to right that equates
to a a ten point move in the SPS in five
minutes and so that just gives you an
idea how powerful this was so from 9:57
all the way up to 973 ish that area you
know you're talking about a 16 17 cent
move you know that's right a 16 17
points in the SPS that's what it equates
to so nice if I find a footprint chart
here you know people asking the what how
many charts different types of charts do
I keep open well you know I said I keep
open different types of charts like here
right I have excuse me have a
five-minute chart I'm trade off of it
but I like to get you know a bigger
picture sometimes you know when you're
staring at a footprint chart sometimes
you know you you just you know
especially a four range chart you're
just dealing with you know five ticks
here but you know by looking at a five
minute chart sometimes it just sort of
gives you a bigger overall picture you
know say sometimes you're a little bit
confused on what's going on into the
market there's there's no law that says
you can't look at another type of chart
during that time anyway we'll go back to
9:30 I had to start my system you know
my ninja trader license for some reason
expired today and I had
go back and forth with NinjaTrader I
don't know why it expired but they had
to go reset it up and everything that's
why I don't have any charge before 9:30
so it's not like my hiding stuff that
happened at 9:30 no you know even myself
you know being a ninja trader the vendor
I still get license issues and you know
license is still have to be updated so
anyway you know you had your divergence
here at 9:57 no reason to be buying in
here but again no reason to be trading
knowing that you got this number coming
out I mean you're just sort of going
sideways in here and I'm not gonna say
yeah you should have bought it because
you got this multiple imbalances in here
then here you got this sign you do have
this you know the red the grooc the
green arrow so you got you know it's a
sign of some trap traders down here but
this is right when a number is coming
out you're not gonna take that trade
you'd be foolish to take that trade
right ahead of the USDA number the USDA
number now has more market impact I
think in a percentage-wise then then
does the non-farm payrolls the
employment numbers so this is all 11 you
know 11 o'clock exactly you know
twenty-one twenty-two twenty seconds
twenty-one seconds 22 seconds 24 seconds
so you're not gonna be trading at that
time i time your order gets in you've
already missed anything you know even
11:05 you got the sell signal here at
966 we got the Delta scalper giving you
a buy actually the Delta surge right
here again you know this is a number
honestly like non-farm payrolls you
should give it at least 15 minutes or 30
minutes for the market to settle down
especially in this in the grains you
should give it more time honestly this
is a day you shouldn't really be trading
at all because you're getting a lot of
positioning going on by commercial
traders okay now it's it's a it's a bit
different between the commercials in
Estate commercials and financials versus
commercials in commodities and I could
talk about commercial traders in
commodities because I was one was I a
commercial trader when I worked at JP
Morgan not necessarily in that sense you
know when your commercial trader in
mati for him like I was a car girl right
you have positions that you got a deal
with I mean physical positions are you
gonna be excuse me oftentimes taken
delivery on and in in financials not
necessarily you know in the bonds yes
but you know you don't think it taking
visit delivery
you don't can't take delivery in the
cash market actually in the futures
market for a minis because its cash
settled grains a different story grains
are physically settled it was
interesting when I when I went to work
at JPMorgan that was in the mid 2000s JP
Morgan had no experience whatsoever in
grains now this was the time when grains
really started a nice bull run and in
the mid 2000s and you know all
commodities went on a carrot in the
mid-2000s and JP Morgan you know they
wanted to get into commodities that's
how I got hired because of my experience
at Cargill and they really had no idea
at whatsoever about deliveries or
anything because you know what JP Morgan
they would trade commodities for for
customers that you know had a need for
it but that was the extent of it they
never did anything about deliveries they
didn't know how to handle notice dates
in commodities or deal anything in
deliveries it's quite funny they would
actually blow get customers out of the
position I don't say blow him out but
get him out of the position ahead of the
notice date because you know they don't
want to deal with delivery the delivery
process it wasn't until after that after
the mid-2000s that they really made a
big push into quantities and it became a
big asset class for them but anyway you
know so this is a market getting back to
this non this USDA number give it 30
minutes to settle down because it is it
is a market like I just showed you on
the five minute chart you know it it had
a 16 17 cent move you know in pretty
quick okay so and you see and you know
during this time you're seeing big
volume go through sometimes you know 230
230 I'll say big volume but you get in
these pockets of big volume in there
right oftentimes when you see the
equities move like the ESPYs move during
the non-farm payroll they do it on
lack of liquidity here you have I in my
opinion I think you got more liquidity
at certain areas then you knew then say
yes peace I hear you got 700 lots going
through and this market is still moving
pretty quick
you know five another 500 right here 200
that's good size volume going through so
you're getting a lot of commercials you
know position you know adjusting
positions in the market you know people
asked well how do I talk about grains so
much sometimes in some of my
presentation so I think grains follow
the order flow much better than some of
these financial markets because you know
it's more driven by supply and demand
you know people need to eat people don't
need to trade equities so anyway as we
get up here towards this high now
there's a few things here right so you
know the number came out at 11:30 11
o'clock and this time it's already 11:30
it's starting to slow down a bit
divergence interracial that fails
another ratio here point control at the
top another ratio that fails you know
this is the market that's on a tear you
know you had a big buying imbalance up
here you got a bearish ratio point
control at the top and is this market
you know once this market picks up I had
this team and it's trending it's just it
just moves you get up here
again you know you have order control at
the top you've got the bearish ratio
you've got you know the imbalance on the
high you test the high again less volume
that's nice and then you start to come
off but can you know is this a day you'd
be looking to trade you really shouldn't
be looking to trade on this day honestly
you know unless you got deep pockets you
know it's not a good day to be trying to
do order flow analysis just because you
got so much undercurrent going on
between positioning people adjusting to
these numbers you know now the you know
the non-farm payroll number you know
people don't people watch it but they
don't trade it like they used to back in
the 90s but this number they're not the
USDA number it does get you a nice nice
moves
okay so here's corn when the number came
out you know the reason why it charged
to look like this is because the data is
coming in so fast it's coming out by the
exchange but the kinetic servers or
oftentimes you know whoever is handling
your data cannot handle it and that's
just why it looks like that you can see
once the market settles down here eleven
1109 it seems to be back in normal the
idea you're at corn right now corn is
moving quite quietly when you tuck in a
low of 350 your high of 355 so you know
you're looking at a five cent move five
and a half range rather but you see how
the number came out right here right and
there's nothing going on for the first
you know a few seconds then it starts
picking up and you're seeing very good
volume go through you see in 700 700
1,700 you know a thousand two thousand
two thousand fourteen hundred you're
seeing some very very good volumes
you know later you hit your high up here
and then you start coming off there so
again you know it's not really a market
it's not gonna say now I'm working and
not a day you want to be trading in the
market it's it's it's a day take it off
from trading the Greens just because
there's there's gonna be a boatload of
volatility you also got you know today
is also a month end as well so it's it
was a bit crazy day in intent in sense
of market movement now let's see what
other grains talk about just give me a
second here talk about wheat because
wheat you know we it's kind of similar
to these other markets
you know wheats normally a good market
to trade as well I don't really follow
it that much anymore but it's decent so
I just sort of go back right before the
number came out here and you can see
it's kind of in a you know it's kind of
in a tight range you know 450 was at two
and a quarter up to 459 but the numbers
and it's just nothing happening here
then you know activity starts picking up
we come down actually making new lows
you know the other markets just rallied
immediately after those after the number
came out and this is you know after this
is already 1101 and 35 seconds so you
can see we just sold off pretty quick a
quick 5 cents in a minute and a half
then we start you know start going up
you know this one is is not as the
volume is not as strong as right now is
as the corn so it moves a little bit a
little bit freer I wants it freer
because corn you know of corn you get a
lot of volume you can get a lot of
volume relative to wheat you know we
could get some decent moves as well you
know this is already one o'clock you
know you're getting this nice little buy
signal down here but you know the
markets closing in 10 minutes more or
less so it's probably not you know
you're not gonna be looking to take any
trade so again yeah I'm just trying to
show you you don't have to trade every
day and especially if there's a big
number that's coming out you don't have
to trade around that number I know you
know a lot of people are attracted to
volatility but volatility works two ways
it could work in your favor and it could
literally kill you right I know people
that you know on days like this have
traded and they gave back all the money
that they earn for the entire month on
this day over a few trades because one
there's a lot of volatility and they
think they got the initial trade right
and they're wrong they get stopped out
and then they take another trade and it
starts going in their favor then they
get stopped out now they're angry
alright and that's the worst thing you
could do revenge trading is the worst
thing you can do as a trader you know I
get back at you market like you know
like you're against the market
and really what you're fighting against
is yourself it's like heaven
you know those cartoons right they'll
comment Jerry right they got you know
the the angel mouse on one shoulder and
the double mouse on another shoulder
it's like which one are you listening to
and when your revenge trading you're
listening to the devil mouse and he's
telling you I you know just increase
your size increase
sighs and get it back you'd only need to
get a smaller move to make your money
back and I've seen people blow up
accounts doing that you know very
quickly because you know if say you're
training a one-lap right and you lose
you know you lose two cents well you do
that a couple times and you're thinking
you're down for you to do that five
times and you lose five cents so next
thing you think is well I'll just trade
you know a to light or a three lock then
I only need to make two cents you know
two cents two and a half cents and I'm
back in the game and I'm back to
break-even know don't you oftentimes
what happens is more often than not that
fails then instead of losing you know
two cents you're trading a three lot
you're down another six cents and it
just snowballs effect until you know
that's what revenge trading is like and
it's it's a bad habit that a lot of
traders fall into you know that's where
it comes into being disciplined right
you should be disciplined as a trader if
you're not disciplined you're gonna get
you're gonna get what say look you're on
you're gonna get thrown around the
market and it's not gonna be pretty it's
not gonna be pretty so that's why days
like this I don't trade on days like
this where I know there's gonna be a lot
of I've often even when I was working I
know that you know the markets will open
tomorrow the next day the markets you
know these grain markets have been
around since the 1800s so you miss a day
it's not gonna do anything unless you
know unless there's a position that's
gotta be dealt with immediately
yeah but you know that's you know when
you're a long-term trader you got bigger
risk parameters that you're dealing with
right it's not you know you have one day
where just immediately you very well now
you know in the past yeah you wouldn't
get 5% moves the way you get them
nowadays but um it's just one of those
things you you don't necessarily need to
trade that day unless you know I mean
obviously unless you have to but if
you're just a small intraday trader you
don't need to trade on a day like today
it's yes it is enticing when you look at
a chart you see a 15 cent move in five
minutes and you want to be involved but
if you're on the wrong side of a trade
on a 15 cent move you're gonna get your
head handed to you and you're gonna want
to quit trading so that's why it's just
best to you know sit back and you know
take a day off you don't need to trade
on those days all right so just really
quick let's move on to a different
market euro currency you know there's
some interesting trades here you had
some nice little cells here and I sell
here the Delta scalper and I sell here
with the Delta scalper and that was that
was it for the day before we closed but
you know you were getting some nice
cells there with the Delta scalper I
really quick one of the things I wanted
to look at because someone had mentioned
to me and I thought it was it was
interesting I wanted to take a look
compared an eight range chart this is
crude oil just sort of go back to this
area here um so you had your low here
around nine rallied up rallied up now
what I want to do those so someone said
you know someone was telling me well you
know you had this range in the crude and
then there was no signals in the Delta
scalper today is it working
well yeah it's dependent on the Delta
right it depends on on the moves in
Delta if it's not gonna give you
anything in terms of you know conditions
being Matt there's not going to be a
signal period you know that's just the
function of it it's not designed to look
specifically for signals I mean it
doesn't make sense what I just said I
say it's not designed to kick off five
ten signals a day it's designed to read
the Delta and if there's something in
the Delta that says hey there's a trade
here yeah it'll give you a trade right
like here's a one-minute chart right
you've got some signals in here you know
you can see some signals in here alright
but you know on the a-train chart you're
not seeing any signals just because it's
the conditions aren't met in the you
know for the day for that for the bars
you know over the period that it's
trying to analyze it so my goal was
actually to compare the eight range to
the four range but you know I don't see
any signals on the eight range actually
so these
and I know I opened the for range chart
I thought I did maybe they didn't save
it correctly when after I opened it the
other day yesterday and I don't see it
anywhere
on my charts no I don't see it but okay
I know I for example I've got a Nasdaq
chart excuse me so I got this cough you
know that's why I haven't been
necessarily been able to reply to a lot
of people because I just feel sick what
it is I hope I'm not dying but some
people say oh so okay so this is a
Nasdaq 8 range I'm sorry for range I'm a
compared to the 8 range you see a nice
cell here this is just make this time
put it a little side-by-side this was at
1024 let's see if you got anything there
at 1024 on the for range hit that high
it's on the high here okay so in the 8
range you had the high for range also
had the high Delta scalper gave a signal
then you had a buy here at 10:28 you
have anything in here no let's see here
this one here at 10:29 you don't have
the cell here this is where that is it's
right here I could tell these numbers
one is 63 is this one at 50 0 and 13 you
add those together I said on an 8 range
it's 1 bar on a 4 range it's split up a
bunch and a bunch of bars because it's
more like you know all these bars right
in here so you got signal there you
don't have it on the 8 range 10:47
nothing let's just look at these signals
this is what 12:40 I'm just looking at
the signals of the a range relative 1238
12:40 mm is this the signal here maybe
I'm not sure I doubt I can't tell 16
okay actually this signal here is
occurring in this bar here not in this
bar so it's not matched up
12:59 there's nothing on the four range
how about this one at 229 where is that
nothing there three o'clock
well you got this cell signal this one
is this one here doesn't work out I mean
it's right on the cash closed you know
how I feel on the cash clothes this is a
nice cell signal right here actually a
little bit after the cash close this bar
at the corner control at the top you got
the imbalance got the bearish ratio
don't have the bearish ratio here partly
because this bar is split up between
these two bars whereas here it's just
one bar so I don't know can you use a
four range as a lead-in to an eight
range you can I mean you saw there's
that one nice trade on the height of the
day where it's sold off from but let's
go back to crude for a second you know
this this high here the swing high I
remember seeing this and thinking oh
this was quite interesting you know you
came up here to the high he got this bar
here small Delta I liked this then he
had very strong Delta minus 783 and end
up at minus 71 and then started selling
off to me that's a nice sign then you
can see the deltas starting to pick up -
70 - 68 though - 76 621 then you're in
this bar here at 6:49 you know to me
that's an area where you should be
looking to sell in here around the 54
area did it really move down not so much
I mean it cut down to you know down to
40 but you know you could have got
something out of this at least ten cents
I mean again you know ten senses is not
very much but you know on a day that's
not really giving you necessarily very
much I do like these bars here you know
you had some positive buying coming in
it's kind of hidden
- 580 delta ends up at plus 31 and the
next bar is strong does circle around
then makes that move back up there
before you closed for the day so anyway
um you know Linda's fortunate enough
going pretty long I don't know if I made
sense I'm on this cough medicine and
that's telling my wife sometimes it
makes me feel a bit loopy but hopefully
you could have saw
you know the number if there's one
takeaway you take from this presentation
is the USDA report effect on the grains
it's like the non-farm payroll number
the unemployment number for the
financial markets USDA report be very
careful trading on that day if you're
trading intraday you know if your
position trading okay you know you have
a bigger risk but if you're trading
intraday you're looking at you know one
cent stop you blow through that like
that in a second so I have a great day
everyone have a great weekend and I'll
catch you guys next week bye bye